[Music]
morgan
is in minnesota to start off this hour
hi morgan how are you
i'm doing well dave thank you very much
dave chris it's a
total honor to be speaking with you
right now you too sir how can we help
so i have a question i uh i'm in i'm 29
years old
my wife is 25 we have two kids we are
both full-time college students
uh she's studying nursing i'm studying
geology
and we have very unstable incomes
and we just found you guys a couple
months ago so we're trying to cash flow
all of our school my school's paid for
from the gi bill
good but we're having trouble creating
a budget when this month we might
bring in 3500 next month we might bring
in 1500.
okay good all right and you got stipend
as well right
correct and that's 1200 isn't it
it's a it's about 1200 but it changes
depending on
the semester and whether classes are
offered online or
now mandated online yeah so you guys
aren't working much
uh i'm staying home with my uh the two
kids for child care and my wife
is working as a cna okay
and so you're not working at all
i do some online work for the va it's
about
a thousand dollars a month okay well you
got 1200 coming from the government
and a thousand is two is 2200 so
i mean your minimum is probably higher
than you outlined originally when you
start talking about this am i wrong
the the only portion that you're wrong
is in between classes so when
summer semester ends and fall begins
there's an entire month
that i don't get that housing statement
okay
picking it up for three weeks yeah you'd
be working more yeah
okay so uh anyway here's the thing you
lay out your budget
on the minimum that you can exist on
and you've got to figure out a way to
bring that in
every month okay the minimum existence
that's food shelter
clothing transportation utilities baby
formula
right the minimum you can exist on
and uh then above that when you make
money you've got a prioritized
spending list of things we'd like to do
uh things we need to do but are not
absolutely necessary for survival
and that list of what is the if you once
you make your
basic budget your four walls then what's
the next thing
and then once you do that what's the
next thing and you make a list of as the
money
does that and you can just keep that on
the yellow pad if you want and then you
can roll it into your every dollar
budget
chris yeah you really can and and morgan
here's the reality
because of the inconsistency it's going
to require more structure
than you've ever had before and and so
in that mindset whenever there is the
opportunity to be able to earn extra or
to work
that's the thing you're doing but what
dave just showed you is you're setting
your baseline
of knowing exactly what has to be taken
care of so any that comes over and above
we're setting that off to the side
because we know we're going to need it
eventually especially come that month
where you you have the gap
you know sometimes when someone's having
trouble budgeting
because of an inconsistent income what
they really mean is they're not making
enough money to eat on
and so you may need to adjust your your
ability to earn
between the two of you uh for a period
just for just to get through these two
degrees
because obviously you've got to have
enough to eat on but if you had an
irregular income that totaled 300 000 a
year you wouldn't never called me
so it's not the irregular part that's
killing you it's the lack of
right and you get down below the line of
necessity
on a couple of these months and you you
know you're in a hole
and if you haven't planned for that hole
and don't have some money set back for
that hole
then you've got a real mess and that's
that's the that's the pinch that you're
feeling
so lay it out and go okay here's our
rent
here's car gas here's lights and water
right here's food right okay food
shelter clothing transportation
utilities in the worst possible month
we can barely exist on
x right and uh you know in the numbers
you gave me
that needs to be under 1500 bucks with
the numbers you gave me a minute ago
because you can you can pretty well
scratch together 1500 on almost any
month
she's a cna you've got some online stuff
right and you know you don't get the
stipend one month you should be able to
scrape together enough to get by
that horrible month but then on the
bigger months where you've got
more than enough then you work your
prioritized spending list
and you can do it all with the every
dollar budget it'll all work out right
there in it
it's designed to help you do that and
you just update it and update it is all
you do